bonjour messieurs merci à tous les deux
d'être en direct avec mons sur rt france
une réunion de plus de deux heures ce
matin et au final un très bref très bref
point presse du premier ministre on
vient de lister les principales annonces
alors que selon des sondages plus de la
moitié des français estiment qu'on ne va
pas assez loin dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
est ce que ces mesures vous semble aller
dans le bon sens c'est ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes alexis poulain
je ne sais pas si elles vont dans le bon
sens elles vont disons dans le sens de
l'ascension généralisée qui est devenu
le lot commun
le problème que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est le contrôle a priori de liberté
d'expression et de la gestion de cette
aide en ligne uniquement dédié et
n'était pas aux plateformes qui décide
par des directs de communauté et au delà
des états et du droit des états de faire
un peu ce qu'elles veulent sur ce
qu'elle montre dans les allures it ce
que nous montre pas et puis la façon
dont elle modère aujourd'hui avec des
modérateurs humains dont le coût social
est assez important puisqu'on parle de
syndrome de traumatismes proche du post
traumatismes de guerre pour les gens qui
sont amenés à modérer ses réseaux
sociaux où effectivement on va trouver
beaucoup de doreur de manière
systématique donc vouloir les modérés
bien avec un bémol
attention à la liberté d'expression
attention à nos libertés
attention à la censure politique à
l'agenda caché qui serait derrière cette
volonté de contrôle de reprise des
réseaux sociaux parce que cette
relativement illusoire de croire qu'on
puisse avoir un contrôle sur ces espaces
là donc je vois que l'europe aussi a
décidé de faire de la lutte contre la
fausse information en pole mais il ya
deux choses on va parler de l'europe
mais un instant si vous le voulez bien
alexis blanc le
le premier ministre a annoncé le
renforcement sans délai ce sont et de ce
sont ses termes d effectifs de la plate
forme de signalement pharos est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il est question il n'est
question que d'effectifs ou bien de
formation aussi pour lutter au mieux les
deux je pense que c'est à la fois la
façon dont les services travaillent
ensemble soit la direction
antiterroriste pharos mais les
directions du renseignement on a un vrai
problème sur la façon dont la france
fait du renseignement aujourd'hui du
renseignement intérieur et dont les de
l'information circule entre les services
donc ça il ya un premier point sur la
formation sur le l'organisation sur le
nombre évidemment 28 personnes dédiées à
faro ce n'était pas assez
tout le monde en était conscient donc
heureusement que le premier réflexe est
de recruter d'avantagé de voir que
chaque signalement envoyé à far aux
pourra faire l'objet d'une enquête ou au
moins être traitée correctement et dans
les temps par cette plateforme qui sait
surnage en fait sur les demandes de deux
signalements de contre-terrorisme
pédophiles et autres donc tant mieux si
si si bien sûr cela permet de renforcer
les moyens de pharos la frêle avec vous
si vous plaidez des sanctions contre
ceux qui publient en ligne des
informations menaçant la vie d'autrui ce
que aujourd'hui c'est l'un des enjeux
principaux de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
non pas vraiment même pas du tout mon
avis là j'étais très toujours très
intéressant cette séquence on a eu
d'abord la séquence sidération
certains ont cru ont découvert qu'en
france il était possible de décapiter
des gens je rappelle qu'en 2016
on a eu plusieurs décapitations peut
citer arnaud beltrame qui a été égorgé
on peut citer le berre hamel qui a été
égorgé au site et les deux policiers de
de l'ouest parisien de la banlieue
parisienne qui ont été égorgés bref
certains s'interrogent
on est dans la sidération deuxième le
deuxième volet comme d'habitude la
gesticulation le verbe la politique
moi j'ai envie de dire et l'action et
que fait-on keim l'action alors si le
premier ministre va à bruxelles pour
essayer de régler les problèmes d'action
en matière de lutte anti terrorisme sur
le territoire français
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux à ce
moment-là conclure tout de suite que les
choses sont mal partis et je vais vous
citer un autre exemple qui est à mon
avis flagrant de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et toutes les problématiques
liées à faro sur réseaux sociaux il est
évident que les policiers s'intéressent
aux réseaux sociaux il ya peut-être
encore des trous dans la raquette mais
globalement cd c'est un sujet qui est
déjà pris en compte
savez vous que dans la majorité actuelle
celle qui a été élue en 2010 est un
majorité on s'interrogeait ces derniers
jours pour savoir si la décapitation du
malheureux professeur pâtit était un
acte plus horrible plus supérieur entre
guillemets que les attentats de novembre
en préparant cette émission je me suis
quand même je me suis dit que j'allais
quand même vous redonner les chiffres
précis de ce qui s'est passé en 2015
13,9 en 2015 par dont les fameuses
attentats des terrasses et du bataclan
129 morts 4 158 blessés 14 juillet 2016
nice 84 morts 354 blessés et figurez
vous qu aujourd'hui on s'interroge pour
savoir si la décapitation de ce
malheureux professeur est un des
éléments plus barbares issue est plus
grave que ce qui s'est passé en 2015
voilà où on en est oh moi je vous dis
c'est bien gentil de s'intéresser à
pharos mais que les politiques les
hommes les majorités qui nous gouvernent
prennent leur responsabilité le premier
ministre a annoncé la création d'un pôle
spécifique au parquet de paris pour
centraliser les poursuites et donc en
améliorer l'efficacité ce sont ses mots
on entendu et on entend dire que tout
existe déjà au plan législatif que
pourrait apporter ce nouveau pôle à
mériadec raffray pardon j'ai pas compris
le foot j'ai pas entendu un pôle
spécifique qui devrait être créé au
parquet de paris pour centraliser les
poursuites et madame on est dans le
gadget on est dans le gadget il existe
déjà plein de choses des couches des
surcouches aujourd'hui on a un
spécialiste de la coordination qui
travaille avec l'elysée le dont le nom
m'échappe actuellement le coordinateur
national voilà qui la coordination
aujourd'hui a énormément progressé entre
les services
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
il ya deux problèmes trois problèmes le
premier c'est que le nombre menace de
nous submerger haut dans le fichier le
fameux fish
le fichier s les seuls radicaliser dans
ce fichier s il ya plusieurs types de de
gens qu'ils soient inscrits mais le seul
radicaliser pour des problèmes
d'islamisme c'est environ 11 12 mille
personnes rien que ces gens là sur 7
sur ce nombre là il y en a il y en avait
jusqu'à présent environ 200 qui était
très surveillée
on apprend par ailleurs que dans ce
fichier là il ya 4000 sur les 12000 ya
quatre mille étrangers et quatre mille
étrangers qui n'est pas français qui
sont surveillés ou éducation fichiers
pour radicalisation on a également les
problèmes des sorties de prison à gérer
on a j'espère que je vais vous donner
les chefs exacts pour pas vous dire de
bêtises je suis en train de les chercher
on a plusieurs centaines de deux
condamnés dans les affaires de
terrorisme qui entre 2018 en 2002 19
2022 pardon va retrouver la liberté
il va falloir aussi les surveiller on a
modifié la voix quand ça récemment il y
a également on estime également qu' à
environ 2000 détenus pour droit commun
le droit commun c'est-à-dire pour de la
délinquance qui seraient susceptibles de
basculer dans la radicalisation et qui
sont aussi libérables voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui et tous tous les experts
aujourd'hui évoque le problème de le
problème majeur de l'islam je voudrais
terminer en citant est à dire on va
juste terminer sur ce point-là alexis
poulain ou est-ce que ça pêche tout
simplement aujourd'hui on le rappelle
cet après midi jean castex doit
s'entretenir avec la présidente de la
commission européenne justement
aujourd'hui quel rôle peut jouer l'union
européenne quel rôle joue-t-elle déjà
dans la lutte notamment contre la haine
en ligne mais plus largement contre le
terrorisme mais le problème aujourd'hui
c'est je crois le l'amalgamme volontaire
fait parler politique entraîne en ligne
et lutte contre le terrorisme sont deux
choses tout à fait différentes même si
vous pouvez avoir évidemment quelques
quelques clics aux nières mais c'est
tout ce problème de l'agenda politique
de la censure des réseaux sociaux qui
est une
un vrai thème politique aujourd'hui on
voit bien que tout est fait la loi à vie
a été là bien avant qu'on parle de
terrorisme
elle était là simplement pour ce
discours de haine soit disant on parlait
d' islamophobie également de toutes les
haines qui pouvait être mise dans ce
panier donc temps que le politique va
faire un agenda politique un jeu avec ça
et ne pas se focaliser sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme qui est une lutte
difficile armée qui demande des moyens
effectivement des moyens à la fois pour
la justice des moyens à la fois pour la
police des voix hier la froide pour
l'armée mais regardons autour de nous
l'opération marque anomalie est en passe
d'être un échec cuisant s'est passé avec
l'intervention française en libye a
permis à la libye d'être aujourd'hui
havre du djihadisme international
la syrie est un problème non réglé
aujourd'hui et et les services secrets
continuent d'utiliser certains groupes
terroristes à des fins d'opérations sur
les territoires donc on est dans un
moment de confusion généralisée où les
politiques regardent par le petit bout
de la lorgnette et vont utiliser encore
une fois l'émotion que suscite
évidemment la mort de ce professeur pour
faire avancer un achat d'un de censure
qui n'a rien à voir encore une fois avec
la lutte réelle contre le danger
terroriste
et ça c'est extrêmement inquiétant parce
que on a l'impression qu'on est obligé
d'accepter ça regarde et l'absence de
débat parlementaire qu'il ya aujourd'hui
sur les mesures d'exception ne serait ce
que pour le coc vide n'est mais aussi
maintenant sur ce qui est en train
d'être créée j'entends marlène schiappa
qui parle maintenant d'un cellule
riposte sur les réseaux sociaux pour
promouvoir un discours républicain
on est en plein dans la propagande du
minivert aurélien on est en train de
créer de la propagande et de la censure
tout ça en même temps parce que le
moment le s'y prête parce que les
français sont sous le choc et et tout ça
devrait passer sans débat à l'assemblée
nationale sans débat sur nos libertés et
elle est la place de la démocratie dans
ce processus qui est un processus encore
une fois dangereux parce que liberticide
et moins de liberté ça ne veut pas dire
plus de sécurité dernier mot avec vos
malades extradé vous vous pensez qu'il
faut aussi agir à l'extérieur de nos
frontières revoir notre politique
internationale en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme
la tournée c'est un autre sujet je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la politique a stationné
largement resserrer nos
action est largement resserré sur le
mali c'est à dire aux avant-postes des
problèmes aujourd'hui que auquel on a à
faire face en particulier pour gérer les
problèmes d'immigration et je voudrais
terminer en rappelant justement ce que
disait un militaire éminent le général
pierre de villiers qui a été patron des
armées il a dit il ya quelques jours
en lançant son livre qu'on était capable
de confiner la france entière pendant
deux mois et demi d'instaurer un couvre
feu de type de guerre militaire sur les
français et on n'est pas capable de
résoudre des problèmes concrets qu'on
connaît tous qui sont à la base de ces
problèmes de terrorisme
l'expulsion des imams qui prêchent la
haine contre la france dans les mosquées
la fermeture de ces mosquée radicale et
le et le et le mettre fin aux à
l'immigration non contrôlée voilà à mon
avis quel est le problème aujourd'hui
est donc je répète c'est pas un problème
de moyens
c'est véritablement un problème de
volonté politique est en fait le
gouvernement aujourd'hui masque on verra
combien de temps va si tu vas vraiment
réagir mais l'or actuellement il agite à
nouveau quelques quelques marionnettes
pour masquer en fait son inaction
politique merci à tous les deux
messieurs maria bakker infra
journalistes spécialisés de la défense
alexis blanc éditorialistes merci
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions sur la france